Alright, so, one of the things that's very helpful about regression is
that in many ways it's very simple to visualize, it's very simple
to think about what some of the issues are and all the
various topics in machine learning that are really important to understand and
sometimes are difficult concepts really do come up in a fairly easy
to understand way. So what I'd like to do now is to
step through an example Of doing some regression and to point out
what some of the pitfalls are and how they're generally handled in
the machine learning context. So, this graph that I put
up here, is, we just made these numbers up, but it's
supposed to tell us a, a little bit about housing
prices. So let's imagine that we're off to buy a house
and What we notice is that there's lots of different
houses on the market, and there are lots of different, sizes,
right. So ,the square footage of the house can vary. And
in this case the houses that I visited can be between,
about 1,000 to 10,000 square feet. And of course, as
you get bigger houses, you tend to get more, the, the
prices tend to go up, too. Alright, so the price
that the house cost is, tends to rise with the size
of the house. So, what I've done here is I've
plotted as a little x say a set of nine houses
that I've observed. Start off over here with a house
that's a 1,000 square feet and cost a $1,000? I don't
know what year this happened in. And we end
up with a house that is 10,000 square feet
and cost about $6,000. Again, I don't. This is
not true in Providence Rhode Island, I'll tell you that.
>> Are you sure?
>> Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
>> Yeah, it's really not true in Atlanta Georgia.
>> So Alright... So, so, so imagine that this is the relationship we
observe. But now we want to answer a question like, Well, what happens
If we find a house on the market and it's about $5,000,
what do you think a fair price for that would be? So what
do you, what do you think, Charles? Looking at this, what do
you think a fair price for a 5,000 square foot house would be?
>> Apparently about $5,000.
>> About, $5,000. Right. So, how did you do that?
>> I looked at the graph, I went over to 5,000 square
feet at the x-axis and I went up. Until I found ,where one
of the x's was on the y axis and I said, oh, that's about 5,000 square feet.
>> Well, but there was no corresponding point for that,
so you had to interpolate or something ,uh, based on the
points that were there you had to kind of imagine what
might, might be happening at the 5,000 square foot mark, right?
>> That's true, although this one was a little easy because
at 4,000 and 6,000 square feet, they were almost exactly the same.
>> Mm, and so that, to you, made it feel like there was probably ,um,
that's probably the level where things in this range would be.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Alright, that seems kind of
reasonable. So sure, though what we're going to
do in this case is actually try to find a, a function that fits this.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Alright ,so what we can do is actually say, well what
if there is a linear relationship. What would be the best linear
function that captures the relationship between the size and the cost. So
,what I have here is, it turns out of all the possible
linear functions, this is the one that minimizes the
squared error, the squared deviation, between these x points
and the corresponding position on green line. So it
finds a way of balancing all those different errors against
each other and that's the best line we've got.
Now in this particular case, it's interesting right, because if
you put your idea of 5,000 square feet. Look
what this line predicts. It's something more like $4,000, right.
Do you see that?
>> I do. That is doesn't seem right to me.
>> It doesn't, yeah, it doesn't really look like a very good fit. But it
does at least capture the fact that there
is increasing cost with, with increase in size.
>> That's true.